matt morgan hat sich was vorgenommen
gemeinsam mit freundin die vor allem
eins verbindet der kampf gegen den
terror in afghanistan oder irak
klettertour in colorado mit white hart
einem verein der sich um alle kümmert
die in amerikas kriegen verletzt wurden
körperlich und seelisch
am 20 juni 2012 bin ich explodiert
erzählte uns jet der damals 22-jährige
war in eine sprengfalle der taliban
geraten
ich erinnere mich wie ich aufgewacht bin
auf dem rücken staub überall ich dachte
es wäre ein traum und ich wäre
eingeschlafen
afghanistan hat sein leben verändert jet
wollte seit mai neben dem terrorangriff
auf die usa soldat werden kämpfen für
etwas großes er beschützte die afghanen
half ihnen beim bau von häusern und
brücken während er den felsen erklimmt
treffen die nachrichten vom hindukusch
ein cabrio ist gefallen das land in den
händen der taliban
ein teil von mir ist wütend und
frustriert
ihr wisst schon so viele leben zerstört
so viel blut vergossen und der region
frieden zu bringen
wir haben milliarden von dollar
ausgegeben um ihr land wieder aufzubauen
und den afghanen zu zeigen wie sie sich
schützen können
aber mit der kultur die sie haben wird
das wohl niemals funktionieren
sie alle halten den abzug aus
afghanistan für richtig auch wenn das
chaos in kabul sie empört am abend
erzählen sie von ihren erlebnissen die
westlichen werte seien zwar in den
großstädten afghanistans angekommen den
menschen in den ländlichen gegenden
seien sie egal
sie wollen ihre islamistischen
lebensweise behalten auch in zukunft und
dann muss man bereit sein die menschen
das tun zu lassen was sie wollen
schlimme es gibt es überall in der welt
aber auch wenn du es noch so gerne
ändern möchtest können wir nicht immer
team america losschicken die weltpolizei
auch wenn wir noch so gerne superman
manchmal muss man die dinge geschehen
lassen
wie jet und michael sagte auch zeigen
dass amerika die rolle als superman
ausgespielt hat jedenfalls in
afghanistan seine rede an die nation
eine klare ansage der abzug ist und
bleibt eine entscheidung für alle
amerikaner die ihr leben am hindukusch
riskiert haben
amerikanische soldaten können und
sollten nicht in einem krieg kämpfen und
sterben in dem afghanische truppen
selbst nicht kämpfen wollen
schrecken hatte joe biden sicher einige
preis nach einer späteren machtübernahme
durch die taliban aber plötzlichkeit und
planlosigkeit erschüttern das vertrauen
in beiden glaubwürdigkeit und kompetenz
wenn er schon auf abzug besteht hätte er
es wenigstens planen können was sagt das
américas freunden weltweit
ihr könnt euch nicht auf uns verlassen
wenn wir euch den rücken zu kehren sei
tier in schwierigkeiten
das ist ein gigantisches debatte
tatsächlich aber hatte ja schon die
trump administration den abzug in einem
deal mit den taliban besiegelt trump und
sein team legitimierten brutale
frauenfeindliche menschenverachtende
terroristen als gesprächspartner auf
augenhöhe
der ausverkauf an die taliban hatte
begonnen meint jim townsend im pentagon
acht jahre zuständig für die nato
deshalb habe sich auch die afghanische
armee zu schnell aufgelöst
es gab wohl das gefühl dass da deals
gemacht wurden zwischen verschiedenen
ebenen der afghanischen gesellschaft und
den taliban
und dass nach inkrafttreten dieser deals
dann jeder auf sich selbst angewiesen
wäre wenn die taliban wieder an die
macht zurückkehrt
tatsächlich warnten die geheimdienste
den präsidenten im juli vor einer
kaskade des zusammenbruchs sollten die
taliban weitere wichtige städte erobern
nur wie schnell das unterschätzte
niemand hat erwartet dass die taliban so
schnell fuhren sie hatten offenbar eine
strategie gleichzeitig im norden und
westen anzugreifen und hatten die waffen
vorher in stellung gebracht aus welchen
gründen auch immer hatten wir keine
quellen an der richtigen stelle die uns
hätten vorwarnen können auch ich weiß
dass die nachrichtendienste den kollaps
afghanistans in sechs bis neun monaten
vorhergesagt hatten aber sie hatten sich
das sagt ausgerechnet der mann der dies
sei vor zehn jahren leitete und dann
verteidigungsminister wurde schon damals
2011 konnten wir in afghanistan sehen
dass die mission der usa und ihre nato
verbündeten gescheitert war die taliban
griffen die versorgungswege des landes
an
wie hier die wichtigste straße zwischen
kabul und dschalalabad
dort besuchten wir die us-basis lvb
fenty von der aus eine woche zuvor die
spezialkräfte aufgebrochen waren rom
osama bin laden im benachbarten pakistan
zu töten die amerikaner waren vielerorts
als besatzungsarmee fast mit den
menschen zuhörte konnte wissen dass hier
niemand der botschaft von demokratie und
menschenrechten
glauben schenkt
es kann keinen frieden in afghanistan
geben nach dem tod von osama bin laden
solange die ausländer hier sind ist
frieden unmöglich die ausländer töten
menschen unterdrücken und bombardieren
sie
auch zwischen afghanen und deutschen gab
es spannungen bundeswehr soldaten
drangen gewaltsam in ein depot der
polizei ein sie verdächtigten
afghanische polizisten beschlagnahmte
sprengstoffe und munition an die taliban
zu verticken statt sie zu vernichten
und afghanistans armee weigerte sich die
gegend von taliban-kämpfern freizuhalten
die afghanische armee sagt sie sei für
das halten nicht zuständig dafür sei sie
nicht da und macht das entsprechend noch
nicht als sie kriegt man zusehen wenn
man in ihrem feldlager vorbeifährt aber
hier draußen sieht und hört man die
nicht trotz aller skepsis kämpften viele
afghanische soldaten die hier
ausgebildet wurden auch tapfer gegen die
taliban doch selten bekamen sie so
hörten wir damals sold und rückendeckung
von korrupten vorgesetzten und politiker
die damalige us-regierung hätte
konsequenzen ziehen
die einfachste lektion aus vietnam irak
und anderen kriegen haben wir nicht
gelernt
man muss einen klaren auftrag
formulieren wenn man streitkräfte
schickt welche mission will man erfüllen
zweitens man muss eine strategie haben
um diesen auftrag zu erledigen und
drittens man muss einen plan haben wann
man zur hölle aussteigt
aber wir haben diese prinzipien in
afghanistan nie umgesetzt
was sommer bin laden zu finden war
einfacher als ein land dessen menschen
nach stimmen kulturen und religionen
getrennt sind zu einem nationalstaat zu
machen der sich irgendwie selbst
verwaltet das ist schwierig
weidens hoffnung dass der afghanische
präsident seinen sturz mit einer macht
beteiligung der taliban hinauszögern
würde vergeben ashraf ghani war ein
weiterer korrupter politiker derzeit
folge im stift
der fall von kabul gehört jetzt zum
vermächtnis von präsident beiden bilder
wie einst in saigon beim beschämenden
ende des vietnamkrieges
im fernen colorado hoffen die wird
erahnen dass amerikaner nie wieder nach
afghanistan müssen auch wenn dort jetzt
die taliban-regierung zweifeln sie nicht
daran dass sich ihr einsatz doch gelohnt
hat
das war es wert dass wir da waren wir
haben die kinder gesehen und wussten
dass sie in sicherheit waren jedenfalls
in der zeit in der wir da war
auch michael ist zufrieden sie hätten
versucht die welt ein wenig besser zu
machen eine zeit lang sei ihnen das auch
gelungen
[Musik]